والان نعود الى المقابله الخاصه التي
اجريناها قبل الحصاد مع فيكتوريا نولاند
مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون
السياسيه وقد سالتها اولا في ملف حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا عن حزمه عقوبات جديده
تستعد واشنطن لفرضها على موسكو والموعد
المتوقع لاقرار هذه الحزمه
نشكركم على اطاحه هذه الفرصه هي المشاركه
معكم هذا اليوم انت محقه بما اننا نقترب
من فصل الربيع نتوقع ان الاوكرانيين يودون
اطلاق هجوم جديد الخريطه الحاليه للاحتلال
الروسي لاوكرانيا خطره جدا لهم لذلك
الولايات المتحده تعمل مع حلفائها
واصدقائها لتوفير ما يحتاجون اليه لضمان
استمرارهم في طرد روسيا من اراضيهم هذه
الحرب كما تعلمون يمكن ان تنتهي غدا اذا
ما اخترت روسيا الانسحاب من اوكرانيا واذا
اوقفت القتال فالحرب ستنتهي اما اذا اوقفت
اوكرانيا القتال فستنتهي اوكرانيا
هم يطالبون بصواريخ بعيده المدى وبمقاتلات
هل يمكن ان تنظر الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الى هذه المطالب
نعمل معهم عن كثب وبكل كثافه بشان ماهيه
احتياجاتهم اذا كانت احتياجاتهم تتضمن
اجهزه دفاع جويه لحمايه اجوائهم واذا ما
ارادوا ايضا مدافع او صواريخ بعيده المدى
لان الرؤوس سحب قوتهم الى الوراء ويطلقون
صواريخ من مدن ابعد لهذا السبب نحن نعمل
مع حلفائنا لتلبيه احتياجات اوكرانيا
والتردد روسيا من اراضيها
طيب اذا ما عدنا الى هذه الحزمه كيف تختلف
هذه الحزمه عن سابقاتها من حيث من حيث
طبيعه والنوعيه الاسلحه المقدمه للجانب
الاوكراني
اعتقد انه في كل مرحله التكتيكات الروسيه
اصبحت اكثر وحشيه ليس فقط فيما يدين
القتال ولكن رايتهم كيف يهاجمون البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه كمنشات الماء والكهرباء
يحاولون تجميد الشعب الاوكراني في فصل
الشتاء سيحتاج الاوكرانيون للدفاع عن
انفسهم ليس فقط الى معدات في الميدان
المعركه وانما ايضا في محيط البنيه
التحتيه الحرجه ايضا في كل مرحله يبني
الروس التكتيكاتهم الخاصه بهم اليوم
يلجاون الى الايرانيين والكوريين
الشماليين وحماس للحصول على السلاح وياتون
ايضا بمزيد من الذخيره العنقوديه
والمدفاعيه بعيده المدى لذا الاوكرانيون
يحتاجون الى زياده قدراتهم اكثر حتى لا
يخسر المعركه
اكثر من مره اشرت بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تناقش مع الحلفاء نوعيه الاسلحه
والمعدات التي يتم تقديمها لاوكرانيا
بولندا عبرت عن استعدادها لتزويد اوكرانيا
بمقاتلات اف 16 كيف تنظر الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لذلك
قلنا لحلفائنا انهم اذا كانوا معنيين
بتزويد اوكرانيا بالطائرات فهذا خيارهم
طائره اف 16 موجوده في دول الجوار وهي
الطائره معقده وتحتاج الى الكثير من
التدريب لكن المهم ان يسيطر الاوكرانيون
على اجوائهم الروس خسر الكثير من الطائرات
والمروحيات ربما اكثر من نصف دفاعاتهم
الجويه اذا هذه هي حرب وحشيه واوكرانيا
بحاجه الى الدفاع عن نفسها
عن احاديث الاسلحه ونوعيه الاسلحه لنتحدث
في الاطار الدبلوماسي وزير الخارجيه
الروس يقول ان الجميع يريد انهاء الصراع
مع اوكرانيا لكن لا احد يرغب في اقناع
اكياف بالمسار الدبلوماسي كيف تردون على
ذلك
هو الذي تقدم بخطه السلام من عشر نقاط
تستند الى ميثاق الامم المتحده لا ارى اي
خطه السلام تاتي من روسيا هم فقط يرمون
بالمقاتلين في بخموت ويزيدون من حده
هجماتهم هذه مقوله شريره من قبل الروس كما
قلت هذه الحرب يمكن ان تنتهي غدا اذا ما
توقفت روسيا عن القتال غدا ولكن اذا ما
توقفت اوكرانيا على القتال فستنتهي
اوكرانيا غدا
لكن الجانب الروسي يقول بان الغرب لا يشجع
اوكرانيا على ان تكون واقعيه في طاعاتها
مع الوضع القائم او المستجد على الارض وهي
ضم اقاليم بالفعل لروسيا من اوكرانيا
كما رايت من التصريحات الروسيه هم يطالبون
ليس فقط من اوكرانيا وانما من العالم اجمع
بالاعتراف بضمهم غير الشرعي وان يعترف
بهذه الاراضي كاراضي روسيه وهي اراد
احتلها خلال المعركه واذا ما فتحنا هذا
الباب فسنفتحه امام كل ديكتاتور وطاغيه
وكل جار كبير ليطلع جيرانه الاصغر طبعا لا
نقبل بذلك وانا متاكده انكم انتم ايضا لن
تقبلوا بذلك وما نقوم به نحن الولايات
المتحده وحلفاؤنا وبلدان مثل قطر التي
وقفت مع اوكرانيا ضد ضم اراضيها هو اننا
نقول للروس لن نقبل بما تقومون به لا يمكن
ان تقرروا ان نصف جيرانكم هي جزء من ارضكم
هذا لن يقبل به احد
اشرت الى وهو كان بالمنطقه بالفعل منذ
ايام ما الذي حققه على مستوى الصراع
الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي
كما تعلمون فان الوضع مقلق للغايه فقد
راينا عنفا في اسرائيل وراينا عنفا في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه ايضا التركيز الاساسي
لرحله الوزير بلينكن كان بدء حوار مع
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده ولكن بسبب
تغير الظروف اصبحت الرحله تتعلق بكيفيه
مساعده الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين لخفض
التوتر والعوده الى الحوار ولكسر دوامه
العنف السيئه هذه والعوده الى مسارحه
للدولتين
هل كانت هنالك خطه امنيه امريكيه تمت
مناقشتها مع الجانب الفلسطيني
وداد
عندما كان الوزير في رام الله بقي مساعده
في اسرائيل للتواصل مع كلا الجانبين وخاصه
في الضفه الغربيه لتعزيز الامن وضمان ان
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين يحمل الناس وان
المؤسسات الامنيه قائمه وتؤدي مهامها وان
هناك قنوات اتصال مفتوحه وسنرى ما ستؤول
اليه الامور لدينا امل ان التوتر سينخفض
لدينا دقيقه واحده فقط اريد ان اسال عن
الملف النووي الايراني المفاوضات متوقفه
منذ فتره ما هي النقطه التي توقفت عندها
هذه المفاوضات ما هي المشكله في هذه
المفاوضات
والله
كان هناك على الطاوله اتفاق شبه كاملا
لعده اشهر لكن ايران اختارت عدم التوقيع
عليه للاسف ايران اصبحت اكثر عدوانيه الان
في انحاء العالم واكثر عدوانيه مع شعبها
في الداخل لديها مشكلات تتفاقم مع ايران
بما في ذلك الدعم الذي يقدمونه لروسيا
كالمسيرات وتكنولوجيا الصواريخ قصيره
المدى وهناك بواعظ قلق حقيقيه الافكار
موجوده بالنسبه الى الملف النووي والحل
موجود ولكن للاسف لم يوافق لرانيون عليها
عملت
شكرا لك يا سيده فيكتوريا نولاند مساعده
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون السياسيه